[Music]
first speaker of the year my colleague
Ilana chef arts longs for the sister I
never had
six years after I did about science got
into science there to graduate work at
Columbia with Ron Breslow and then did a
postdoc with Peter Durban remember the
Yale corporation
you've been on the faculty here ever
since winning teaching awards in organic
chemistry and becoming it years ago
member the natural design force to be
dealt with
you'll you'll definitely see
know what happens so join me thank you
professor zoom is this is this on can
you guys let me turn it up can can you
can you hear me in the back
just nod okay better so thanks to
professor zoom it is true that when I
interviewed for my job here at Yale
professor zoom and his colleague
professor Johnson took me to a bar at
some point and told me what a wonderful
community it was and how much fun I
would have and how much I would grow as
a scientist if I was here at Yale and it
certainly has been true and so he really
is but I don't have a brother but he is
the brother I never had
and so one of the things he said I
needed to do here is tell you a little
bit about how I became interested in
science and so in addition to talking
about what proteins and polymers have in
common which I will describe well we're
also going to have a little bit of kind
of amusing stories about what it was
like to grow up in Rego Park Queens and
some of the fun things I did as a
seventh grader okay so the first thing
is what do proteins have and polymers
have in common okay so I just want to
answer that question initially so that
we can get on to kind of more detailed
analysis okay so what proteins and
polymers have in common is really one
thing and that is that they both contain
an ordered array of subunits just like
beads on a string okay but they have
they are different and you can see how
different they are because what I show
you in this image is the picture of a
protein it happens to be silk okay and
so what we will learn today is that one
of the features that makes silk have
such interesting properties as a fabric
is that it has regions like this which
called beta sheets and that those
regions the interactions that are
illustrated by these yellow strands help
makes silk are warm resilient and very
strong fabric okay but you can see
immediately that this picture doesn't
look anything like this picture so this
is a protein the fiber called silk this
is nylon you know like you have in
stockings or spandex or not spandex
board leggings okay and what you can see
easily is that this picture doesn't look
anything like this picture this is far
simpler okay this just looks like a long
strand whereas it's clear that the
protein silk is very complicated it
starts over here it winds its way in
this region goes back and forth and back
and forth and back and forth and in fact
it is more many copies of this central
unit that makes silk such a wonderful
fabric okay so that's what they have in
common but they also have many things
that are completely different okay so I
want you to look at the image on the
upper left so this is the chemical
structure of silk and so what you should
notice is it's got this backbone okay
which is which starts with a nitrogen
that's a carbon another carbon it has an
oxygen that a nitrogen carbon carbon
nitrogen carbon carbon nitrogen and it
continues with exactly that backbone but
what's different is that in highlighted
in yellow what I show you is this the
exact structure of that subunit is not
the same as the exact structure of that
subunits this is an amino acid called
glycine this is an amino acid called
serine we have another glycine and then
we have something brand-new called
alanine and so what makes proteins
different from polymers is that proteins
have a defined sequence of twenty
different amino acids in a prescribed
order
that's dictated by your genetic code in
contrast to that a polymer is nowhere
near as complicated okay so this is
nylon down here and so if you look at
the structure of nylon what you see is
that there's this unit in blue when you
start out with nitrogen carbon carbon
carbon carbon carbon carbon another
nitrogen so that's one subunit you move
over and look at what's next along the
chain and it's slightly different so now
you have a carbon that's bonded to
oxygen carbon carbon carbon carbon
another carbon bonded to oxygen and then
a nitrogen and then if you look at the
next subunit it's exactly the same as
the first and so the fundamental
difference between proteins and polymers
is that proteins have a defined sequence
of amino acids 20 different color beads
that are arranged in a specific sequence
that makes one protein different from
the next
whereas polymer is even the most
complicated polymers known have only
three monomers and currently it is
impossible to control their order and as
a result proteins have this emergent
property where they fold into unique
structures like silk polymers like nylon
can't do that and so the reason I bring
up the differences between proteins and
polymers is because one of the projects
that we're working on in our lab now is
to try to figure out how to build
polymers like nylon that fold up into
shapes like proteins and to do that
we're using a machine that's used in
your cells to make proteins it's called
the ribosome okay in the ribosome the
structure of the ribosome is shown here
the structure of the ribosome was solved
by Tom Stites one of my colleagues in
the mbb Department and for that
discovery he won the Nobel Prize in
Chemistry and so the basis of today's
talk is to tell you a little bit about
why we want to use the ribosome
to make polymers that resemble proteins
but first professor zoom oh and so I
just have to say that that's being done
by a Center at Yale that's called the
Center for genetically encoded materials
which is abbreviated C gem and if any of
you are old enough so that your parents
let you use Twitter you can you can go
to our Twitter page and read about
developments having to do with sequence
to find polymers on the Internet okay so
but first professor zoom told us said
that it was really important for me to
talk about how I became interested in
science so I'll do a little bit of that
and then I'll tell you about kind of the
origins that led us to the program that
seeks to develop sequence to find
polymers okay so first I grew up in a
place in Queens called rego park how
many of you know how many of you have
heard of real whoa very good okay okay
so there's rego park okay this is a
higher resolution view of rego park okay
and so what I just want you to notice
that this road here is called a lawn on
an expressway and that's the road that
you take if you travel from Manhattan to
JFK Airport
how many of you have driven from
Manhattan to JFK airports ok you've
driven right past my house ok literally
I mean I'm actually not kidding right
past my house because in this little
corner of rego park where where you know
the Long Island Expressway just before
you get to Flushing Meadow Park is this
you know development of five skyscrapers
called Park City Estates this is the
building I grew up in which you can see
from you know in the taxi as you're
going from Manhattan to JFK you can wave
to my mom who still lives on the ninth
floor if it's building and our Terrace
is over there on the right anyway so
that's where I grew up and I went to
public school in New York and I went for
a short time to a high school in
Manhattan known as Stuyvesant and we'll
talk about that in just a minute ok so
that's where I grew up
ok but then here's the we have a quiz
now so this is a picture of my sixth
grade class
at PS 206 just across the street from
Park City estates
and you know the truth is that I still I
still interact with some of these people
and so this young man this you know
sixth grader here Harlan rich he's in
ear eye nose and throat doctor at brown
and we still are friends this is Murray
Abrams we're still friends this is dawn
whose name I don't remember but we're
still friends Lisa litera Chuck oak Oh
Chet Glen mones what an incredible group
okay so the question is which one is
Alana okay and I have to say that I gave
I gave this quiz to the all the
first-year graduate students in
chemistry two years ago and they got it
totally wrong and so I'm actually
curious to see all right so there are
two possibilities I think that are
reasonable so one possibility is that
this is me and the other possibility is
that this is me okay so how many of you
think that it's the sixth grader with
the red star how many of you think it's
a sixth grader with the blue star see
you're totally wrong that story
Kimmelman okay that's me it's act so I
think it's in just so is it the glasses
anyway so yes and I actually still
remember that I would have a pin that
had a peacock on it that I remember from
sixth grade okay all right so science so
Kurt asked me if I could think back and
think about when when I began to realize
that science was cool and it was in
seventh grade and in seventh grade at
Halsey Middle School in Queens I had a
terrific biology teacher who told us
that who set us on a gave us a project
and he said he gave us a jar that had
chloroform in it with a rag and he said
I want you to go into a vacant lot and
collect bugs would this ever happen
today but so so I dutifully
went into a vacant lot which was you
know two blocks from where I lived and I
went and I got some bugs you know and
you had to use the top of the jar to
catch the bug and so there were leaves
inside but you know this tween
is not a tropical environment and so the
bugs are not huge right they were small
they're beetles I was not impressed and
so I complained when I got home I had
all these bugs and they were you know I
put them in a cigar case with little
pins and you know it could have ended
there but I was complaining about the
fact that the bugs were small and
although Queens is not a tropical
environment Miami is a tropical
environment and in Miami they have
whomping big bugs and in fact my
mother's parents Flo and Marie Warren
lived in Miami and so my mom said Alana
why don't you just ask grandpa Marie to
go out to the pool and find you some of
those the gigantic cockroaches that they
have in Florida I'm not kidding
and in fact just so that you don't know
how big these cockroaches are that's how
big these cockroaches are there called
palmetto bugs they're Latin name is Yuko
URI kotas flora Dona and they're
actually called Florida wood cockroaches
they are charred they are really big
okay and sure enough my grandfather you
know at age 70 went out to the pool got
me two gigantic cockroaches I mean
really big put them in his own little
jar with chloroform I think he used
carpet cleaner he sent them to me in
this wrapped box like a present and I
stuck them right in the center of that
cigar case and you know I won first
prize for that bug collection and at
that point I realized that science could
be really fun and so that was my but I
don't have a picture I actually called
my mother last night and asked her if by
any chance she had saved this and she
laughed she said that she said that that
was gone as you went to college so but
there it is and so that was my seventh
grade buck like so this is me and this
is my sister Karen who lives in Brooklyn
and these are Leslie and Laurie
Bronstein who were good friends back
then so that was seventh grade okay so
after high school my
ended up going to SUNY Albany so now
we're gonna get begin the more serious
part of the talk I went to SUNY Albany
so if any of you have been to Albany and
the center of the campus is this big
beautiful fountain but I learned a lot
about I learned a lot at Albany right I
learned a lot about how to work in a lab
I learned a lot about how fun it was to
actually do chemistry and I had the
benefit of an extraordinary mentor you
know the truth is that when I went to
college I was only 16 and so I was
really a little kid and so it was really
helpful to me to find someone at SUNY
Albany whose lab I worked in you know
who in some sense not only did he teach
me how to be a good scientist but
because I was all you know I was younger
than everyone else he actually helped me
grow up into a reasonable person I have
to say being in college at 16 is not a
fun thing and he was very helpful in
helping me navigate many of the
challenges that present themselves when
you're two years younger than everybody
else okay and his name was Shelly Bank
and he passed away a few years ago but
he was phenomenal and you know at that
time SUNY Albany had an undergraduate
chemistry program but not much of a
graduate program and so the beauty was
the lab was basically me and a couple of
under other undergraduates and so all of
the research that the Bank Group did and
published in that time was done by you
know SUNY undergraduates who were really
interested in chemistry and all of us
had had Shelly Bank as a professor for
organic chemistry and in fact you know I
had him for my second semester of
organic chemistry as a sophomore I
worked in his lab that summer and I
worked in his lab every summer after
that until I went to graduate school
okay so let me tell you about some of
the things I learned I learned a little
bit about lab dynamics because one of
the other undergraduates in the lab was
not very safe around sodium sodium as
many of you know will catch fire if it's
exposed to water and so it was really
minoo it it was a little scary and one
of the things that I had to do as an
undergraduate is try to work with
Professor bank to help this
undergraduate learn how to
work more safely in a lab and so that
sounds really serious but learning how
to do that and how to be assertive to
know that something isn't right and fix
it that was a really important thing to
learn okay the other thing I learned at
SUNY Albany was to have respect for
equipment and safety because the truth
is another thing that happened at SUNY
Albany which wasn't fun while it
happened but taught me an enormous
lesson is that I had an explosion so one
so I so I was doing something I wasn't
allowed to do which is to work alone in
a lab on a Saturday I was working on my
physical chemistry lab homework and I
had put something in the hood to
recrystallize and I forgot about it
and the next thing I know it was not a
huge explosion so it wasn't scary but it
certainly completely destroyed the
beaker and so that taught me an enormous
lesson about how to have respect for the
chemicals that we work with in the lab
you know and I think that that's an you
know no one was hurt there was no damage
but it was a shock okay because it had
never happened to me before and I
learned at that point that one had to
always put safety first in a laboratory
and I still do that today with my
graduate students and I like to think
that the whole chemistry department is
incredibly safe but I think that having
that coal having that happen at such an
early age made me realize how important
safety is for everybody else okay and
the other thing is that the truth is
that good mentorship really can alter
the course of your life because it's
really true that I never would have gone
to graduate school was it not for Shelly
Bank you know I was a senior I was
younger I loved chemistry but I really
didn't know what to do and he said well
why don't you apply to Columbia it has
the best organic program in the country
and I thought okay and I did and I was
accepted and and now I'm here okay so
Columbia
so after SUNY Albany I went to Columbia
for graduate school and I had the good
fortune of another phenomenal mentor his
name is Ronald Breslow and he just
passed away last year and I learned more
from Ronald Breslow in me because the
truth is that
Ronald was very hands-off you know he in
some sense knew he had people who were
really enthusiastic about science and
people who wanted to discover things and
so he would he just you know he gave you
an idea and then he would say go to the
library and figure out you know what you
should do that's kind of scary and it
turns out that I went to the library and
thought about his idea and I actually
realized that his idea was not the best
idea okay so he had you know drawn
something on the board this complex that
had zinc in it that was reliant on zinc
which is a metal and so what you guys
eventually will learn when you take in
organic chemistry is zinc is a unique
metal because it kind of moves around
very easily so it's never very tightly
bound to any ligand and complex and so
it's very it will you know go from you
know one leg into the next ligand and
you know it's very hard to keep it in
one place and the the project that he
had suggested to me really demanded that
the metal stay in one place and when I
went to the literature and I started
reading about you know these different
complexes I realized that thinks but
zinc wasn't the right metal that cobalt
was the right metal because coal both
three as you will learn when you take
inorganic chemistry it stays in one
place like it you know it's bound to
some ligands in a complex and you can
change its environment but it requires
very forcing conditions and so I went
back to Ronald and I said he wasn't
Ronald then he was professor Breslow and
I said you know I wonder maybe this
would be a better project if we
substituted zinc instead of cobalt and
his eyes lit up and he said you know
you're exactly right and as a result I
had I you know in graduate school my
project was to make molecules that look
like this that have cobalt in the center
and not zinc and what we were I was
doing was trying to understand how that
metal would make a protein fall apart
more quickly in the active site of an
enzyme and that's what I did so the
other reason that working for Ronald was
important is because he was not just
good at forcing you to become
independent but he was also unbelievably
poor t'v okay and so the truth is that
you know I had arrived at Columbia from
SUNY Albany which is not Yale okay
although most of my classmates the other
first-year graduate students who are
from places like Yale and Berkeley
places that had really oh hi oh state
places with huge science programs right
and I had gone to a school that didn't
even have a graduate program and so I
kind of felt like I was you know work I
was you know it was an uphill battle for
me to succeed at Columbia and so I
worked really hard you know I tried to
learn everything that I didn't think I
had learned in college and I worked hard
at my classes and I worked hard in the
lab and one Sunday in my when I was a
second-year graduate student and so you
know I would have been all of you know
21 at that point I was in lab on a
Sunday night and I was all alone or
there were very few people on the floor
and I turn around and so the music was
very loud okay because I was all alone
and if any of you want to know it was
probably the Grateful Dead
but whatever okay so it was very loud
and all of a sudden I turned to my right
and he's standing in the doorway and
he's looking at me with this funny look
on his face and the first thing he did
is he asked me to turn down the music
cuz as I've come to learn it's not his
favorite anyway so turn down the music
and he looks at me and he says Elano you
know what do you want to do with your
life and you know I was young and you
know not sure I really be even belong to
Columbia and so I said I said oh I don't
really know and he looked at me without
a smile and he just said well Alana and
I literally said these words he said
Alana if someone offered you a job at a
place like Berkeley would you take it
and he really said that and I look
tonight my eyes lit up and then he went
through another school he probably named
Yale second okay he went through another
school and at some point I said well you
know maybe he might be interesting and
then he looked at me and he said well
you know you just keep doing what you're
doing
you could get a job at a place like that
you know just keep working as hard as
you are and from that moment forward all
of the imposter syndrome that I had been
experiencing completely disappeared
right because that validation the fact
that he told me that you know I could
get offense
job in science that was all that I
needed to be you know laser focused on
that goal and so you know he was a
phenomenal person and and I don't think
I'll ever forget that Sunday night in
the lab okay and the other cool thing
about Columbia is that I made friends
that I still have for life I mean these
are just 1 2 3 4 5 these are 10 people
who are at Columbia and graduate school
when I was at Columbia and graduate
school and they are now on the faculty
at all these fantastic schools and
companies there's even my friend and a
pile in the mcdb department and we are
literally friends for life it's like
we're family
and I think one of the most fun things
about going to graduate school is that
you form bonds with people that are as
strong if not stronger than the bonds
that you have now with your friends ok
so now for the real science part alright
so what I want to do for the remaining
time is I want to tell you a little bit
about proteins and the features that
give proteins their unique properties
and that will lead into a clear
understanding of why we're spending so
much energy trying to make polymers
chemical polymers that behave like
proteins ok so let's just talk about
what a protein is so I said it was like
beads on a string ok and so the so the
words that we use is that proteins are
natural polymers we call them
biopolymers and the beads you know each
of the beads that constitute these beads
on a string are molecules that are
called
alpha amino acids and this is the
structure of an alpha amino acid so it
has a nitrogen a carbon another carbon
that forms something called a double
bond to an oxygen and then when they're
monomers that carbon is also bonded to
another oxygen and this is what a an
amino acid would look like in three
dimensions and so it's cool about the
central carbon some of you will know is
that since it's sp3 hybridized it exists
as a tetrahedron which means that the
four bonds come off as this and this and
what you what is unique about that
carbon is that it is
it is chiral in which and what that
means is that if you make a mirror image
if you look at the mirror image they're
not superimposable okay so the primary
structure of a protein which is the
simplest way that you can describe it
has to do with the order of 20 different
alpha amino acids and so what I mean by
20 different alpha amino acids is that
all amino acids look like this except
this group here this R group is not the
same and so there are 20 different R
groups and each one of those the
molecules having each one of those R
groups has a different name and what
makes a protein unique is the order in
which those are those amino acids are
arranged so it's like you're making a
bead bracelet and you'd build them with
a specific pattern and if you and the
next bead bracelet you make has a
different pattern of those 20 different
beads and in the case of proteins what
that means is that often will fold into
a completely different structure okay so
these are amino acids and when I say
that they're polymers what happens is
that the nitrogen on one amino acid
monomer reacts with the this is called a
carbonyl group it reacts with the
carbonyl group of another amino acid
monomer and this is what the sequence of
a protein would look like when written
as in a in two dimensions and so what
you can see is that you know this is
called the end terminus of the protein
because it has an NH 3 group and so the
first amino acid in this protein has
this R group are 1 the second amino acid
has that our group are 2 and then you
have you know up to a hundred or a
thousand other monomers in any given
protein and then finally you have the
last amino acid and the c-terminus of
the protein which has a carboxylate
group and that's what it's called okay
so that's the primary sequence and that
is really where all of the information
is and so there are different proteins
that carry out reactions in your cells
and each one of those proteins has a
different arrangement of these 20 amino
acids a different arrangement of these
individual R groups
what's cool about proteins is that
that's equal
contains in most cases contains all of
the information necessary to take that
long string and fold it up into a unique
three-dimensional structure that is
stable okay and so but the first type of
folding that occurs is something called
local structure in which short regions
of that primary sequence fold into
subunits that we call HeLa Caesar sheets
and so there are short so this shows the
structure of an alpha helix this shows
the structure of a beta sheet they don't
look like each other and so those are
things called secondary structures so
those are little elements of structure
that a that that function when regions
of a primary sequence that are
relatively close to each other
fold upon themselves to generate local
proximal structure okay so these local
structures are known as alpha healers or
beta sheets and these alpha helices and
beta sheets are the building blocks to
assemble larger globular proteins okay
and this is what so this is illustrates
how that can happen so this is a protein
known as myoglobin it binds oxygen using
a a cofactor known as heme this is a
really cool protein known as green
fluorescent protein this is the protein
that makes jellyfish be fluorescent in
the sea okay and what you should notice
is that if you look at this structure of
myoglobin what you should be able to
detect is that there are lots of HeLa
C's there's a helix there another helix
there a third helix there in fact it's
almost completely alpha helixes and what
is unique about myoglobin is how those
individual HeLa C's which are elements
of local structure fold on themselves to
generate a three-dimensional structure
that has that carries out chemical
reactions in this case the binding of
oxygen on the other hand if you look at
GFP what you see is that it doesn't have
it has maybe one helix down here but on
almost everything looks like this long
strand those are beta sheets just like
it are found in silk in this case the
roll
those beta strands which are assembled
into a barrel is that inside that barrel
is a chemically SR sidechains like to
the are groups that react with
themselves to generate generate an
organic molecule that absorbs light and
flores's it's really it's one of the
coolest proteins known right not only
because it fluoresce is but because it
fluoresce is because of a reaction that
occurs in the center of this beta barrel
through side chains that are held into
close proximity by the three-dimensional
structure okay okay but what's even more
cool about proteins is it doesn't end
here so it is true that some proteins
are monomers so they are just a single
strand of amino acids that fold into
local structures and then those local
structures fold into these more globular
structures but sometimes those globular
structures interact with each other
so for example this is hemoglobin which
also binds oxygen right in a very
special way and what you could what you
might be able to detect is it kind of
looks like it's four monomers of
myoglobin that have come together here's
one here's a second here's a third and
here's a fourth so it's not exactly
myoglobin right but one of the unique
properties of hemoglobin which is to
bind oxygen and then deliver it right to
a site where it's needed has to do with
its ability to fold into this cordon
Airy structure which alters its ability
to release the oxygen upon demand kind
of an even more interesting assembly of
proteins is in viruses and so this image
shows rhinovirus which is the common
cold that causes gives everyone colds in
the winter and Rhino virus doesn't
consist of four copies of a given
protein it consists of 60 60 copies of
four different proteins that are
arranged into a virus that actually is a
life-form right and gives us all runny
noses in the winter okay so what so so
those are the four elements of protein
structure there's a sequence the
sequence folds into local structures
which are often HeLa C's or sheets the
HeLa C's are sheets for
up into these three dimensional arrays
that are all different from one another
and sometimes those three-dimensional
rays interact with each other
okay so what's so special okay so what's
so special about proteins and what makes
them another reason that they are
different from any polymer known yet is
that they exhibit something called
cooperative folding okay so let me give
you an analogy so how many of you have
made pudding made pudding made pudding
okay I've made pudding okay I have a saw
me makes loves pudding okay so you make
pudding so you add the mix right to a
cup of milk on the stove you heat it up
it turns you know chocolate looks very
delicious but it's too hot and it's very
thin okay and so then you take the
pudding and you pour it into four little
cups and you set it aside or in there on
the refrigerator and how many of you
have peeked at the pudding like before
it's done doesn't anyone pee I peeked at
the footage a peek at the pudding okay
so you peek at the pudding and what you
find is that as time goes on the pudding
first gets a little colder and then it
gets a little thicker and then finally
it's thick enough to eat there isn't a
moment it's not it's there isn't in no
case when you're watching the pudding is
there an instance where you look at it
in the refrigerator at minute 10 and
it's still thin and then you come back
in a minute 11 and it's magically thick
and cold it never happens and that's
because pudding folds non cooperatively
right so the transition from this liquid
that is thin to this solid that is thick
and you know good to eat right it's
basically a linear process so time goes
on it gets thicker and thicker and
thicker and thicker and cooler and
cooler and cooler cooler and eventually
you can eat it not like proteins
okay proteins you heat them up okay and
they stare at you so you have a pudding
in a little Eppendorf tube and you apply
heat to it and it just laughs at you so
you heat it and you heat it and you heat
it and nothing happens it's still the
same protein that it was and then
magically you hit a temperature called
the folding temperature and in a
microsecond all of the molecules of
protein that are
staring at you and are still folded up
into this three-dimensional structure
like this you heat it and you heat it
and you heat it and nothing happens and
then magically at one instant you've
reached this temperature and the whole
thing unfolds okay that is the
fundamental difference between proteins
and polymers okay and the fact that that
happens is one of their is in fat so
that is a unique property of proteins
and so if you scientifically you'd call
this a melting curve and so if you
increase the temperature it's an it's
folded it's folded its folded folded and
then BOOM it's not folded and what's
even more amazing is that if you were to
look with them you know with any sort of
chemical tool at the composition right
in the middle of this transition what
you would not see are molecules that are
half folded what you would see instead
is a one to one mixture of molecules
that are fully folded and molecules that
are completely unfolded and that is the
magic of proteins for polymers you know
you start at low temperature you
increase the temperature you know and
you undergo this linear transition
between completely folded and completely
unfolded without this jump where
everything unfolds individually so there
are no polymers known that that carrot
that fold in this way until 2007 okay so
until 2007 the only molecules on earth
that underwent this unique cooperative
folding unfolding process were natural
proteins and some nucleic acids like the
DNA that's in your chromosomes that was
it but in 2007 I had two fantastic
people in my lab James Peterson who's
now at the University of Pennsylvania he
teaches chemistry and Doug Daniels who
now is in charge of entrepreneurship at
the University of Dayton and what they
did in my lab in 2007 is they actually
discovered the first chemical polymer
that shows that cooperative folding
transition and this was really cool
because Paul Florie who is you know the
most famous polymer scientists in the
world and won a Nobel Prize
you know he would write article saying
that there are no examples of the only
proteins that are ate that should be
able to show this cooperative there was
so that the property of cooperative
folding was a privilege that only
natural proteins would have but what
Doug Daniels and James Peterson showed
is that this was not the case because
what they did in my lab in 2007 is
design a sequence of a chemical polymer
it's called a beta peptide that folds
into a three-dimensional structure that
looks a lot like myoglobin it still has
HeLa C's and in fact we've made others
that have loops between the Gila C's and
what's really amazing about these
unnatural proteins is that they exhibit
all of the hallmark hallmark properties
of proteins found in nature they unfold
cooperatively they have a unique
three-dimensional structure in water
they can be designed so that you alter
the fold and this is the
three-dimensional structure of one of
those molecules that shows how you have
this cool hydrophobic core in the center
ok so that brings me to the ribosome and
so one of the challenges that we faced
when we study those unnatural proteins
is that they were really hard to
synthesize and we couldn't use biology
to make variance because the monomers
that made up those unnatural proteins
are monomer is that the ribosome which
makes proteins in your cells would
eschew okay so the ribosome has evolved
for billions of years to do one thing
and one thing only which is to make
proteins ok so there's an mRNA code and
the tRNA is bind and you get AM advanced
forms and and and as far as we know the
only types of polymers that the ribosome
can make are polymers that are composed
of the Alpha amino acids that I showed
you and so what we began to wonder is
whether or not we could make beta
peptides like the molecules that were in
that structure I showed you previously
using the ribosome and in fact two years
ago Clarissa check stir who now has her
own laboratory in Scotland was able to
achieve that goal
she was able to identify a ribosome that
was that started out as the normal
ribosome that was found in e.coli and
she generated a Meucci identified a
mutant ribosome a ribosome that had a
slightly different RNA sequence that was
able to incorporate one molecule of a
beta amino acid which happens to be a
constituent of nylon into a protein and
that allowed us to to to win an enormous
grant from the National Science
Foundation that that is allowing us to
try to figure out how to repurpose the
ribosome to biosynthesized not natural
proteins but chemical polymers that are
like proteins in that rather than having
a random array of monomers which is what
chemical polymers have now instead they
have a very well defined sequence of
monomers with the expectation that those
chemical polymers will then fold into
three-dimensional structures that have
unique functions and that's what we're
trying to do and so we're you know one
of the things we're trying to do is
generate proteins that have a small
number of these monomers in them that
makes them more stable and allows them
to be stored on shelves for longer if
their protein therapeutics we're also
trying to make fabrics that are you know
somehow a Camile ding of nylon and the
material that's in bulletproof vests to
make those fabrics lighter so that they
wouldn't be so heavy for law enforcement
people to carry and we're also trying to
make unique materials that let's say
encode information and so so you could
for example identify where you're you
know where if you take penicillin in a
little pill right there would be a
little a little sensor or a little tag
in that pill that would say where it was
made and when it was made so that you
wouldn't in fact be a tag on your
prescription bottle they're all quartz
with all sorts of different cool things
you can do using polymers if their
sequences are defined and this just
shows a little bit of how we're going to
do it so we're going to use back
area and in these bacteria we're gonna
have ribosomes that we identify we call
them designer ribosomes and we're gonna
have to design some enzymes that make
the substrate for the ribosome so we
call them designer enzyme trna pairs and
these are some of the polymers that we
want to make and well I think the most
fantastic thing is that we're not doing
this on our own you know so not only do
I have a fantastic group of people in my
lab but I get to work with fantastic
people all over the country and so in
addition to my lab so this Center this
NSF funded Center I work with dieter Sol
who maybe has given a science on
Saturdays and talked about the genetic
code it's got Miller who could give a
science on Saturdays and talk about
catalysis Jeff Townsend who can give a
science on Saturdays and talk about
statistics so these are all people at
Yale we also get to work with two
fantastic scientists on the west coast
we should das who is the maker of a
video game called eterna
which allows you to fold rnase as if it
was a how many of you is anyone heard of
a turner well you should look it up
because it's really fun like it actually
gets you it allows you to fold your
whole your own RNA molecule as a video
game and then Jamie Kate who's a
fantastic structural biologist who is an
expert at determining the structures of
the ribosomes that we make using
high-tech cryo-em methods and so you
know with this Center for genetically
encoded materials we're trying to ask
the fundamental question of what
properties one might what might emerge
from a chemical polymer whose sequence
was defined the same way that the
sequence is defined in a natural protein
I'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you
do you need a mic yep I was wondering
what is the difference in proteins
purses
polymers that actually causes the
protein to do this cooperative goal so I
think that so the simplest answer to
that is when proteins fold so proteins
that are well folded often in the inside
have a region that has lots of
interactions between those are groups
it's called the hydrophobic core okay
and the assembly of that hydrophobic
core is is comes out of the primary
sequence and so there are only certain
prime I mean there you can imagine that
there's an almost unlimited number of
primary sequences and so proteins that
are folded the arrangement the
arrangement of amino acids is such that
when the protein folds it has this
cement like interior
in contrast polymers don't do that right
because they have very few monomers and
they're not arranged in a specific
position in a specific array and so they
never fold into that well-defined
three-dimensional structure that is
really held together through multiple
interactions of residues that are very
far apart and so you heat them a little
bit and you get some kinetic energy and
things start to move around but the
force holding that hydrophobic core
together is so strong that it resists
that temperature until you reach the
folding temperature and then poof
everything falls apart and so that's why
the sequence matters right because some
sequences don't form structures that are
well folded okay and in those cases you
sometimes you don't have to heat them at
all and they're just unfolded chains
okay young man over there
[Music]
there are there are lots of different
types of proteins so in our cells there
are probably if you count alternative
versions of the same sequence there are
maybe a hundred thousand different
proteins you know at the simplest level
that level there are about 24,000
different proteins and each one of those
different proteins has a different job
and so there and in different organisms
there are different proteins and so
there are an enormous number of
different proteins and many of them look
very different from one another yes
they're in yes in fact some meats have
certain proteins and you know different
kinds of fish have different proteins
yes that's exactly right you're welcome
okay yes in the back
so the honest truth is that that
structure was an accident so what we
design so so if you remember the
structure I showed of a helix so at that
point in time there was a lot of
interest in things called coil coils
which are structures in which you have
to he listens and we were asked we
thought we were asking a very simple
question we simply tried to design a
chemical polymer that assembled into a
version of that coil coil where two
short Gila C's would come together and
interact and what we discovered is that
although that's what we had designed
what we actually had formed was that
globular structure and in retrospect we
should have known better right but it
turns out that the sequence that we
designed had the requisite side chains
so that it would assemble into the
globular fold that I just described and
so it you know we were but for about six
months we didn't know what we had done
because we knew it wasn't an assembly of
two strands we knew it either had six or
eight strands and it wasn't until we
solve the structure that we knew that it
was this octo Marik assembly and in that
was even amazed more amazing is that the
teeth at the temperature that you have
to reach in order for those eight
strands to fall apart is almost boiling
okay so most proteins in nature have
melting temperatures of let's say 50
degrees plus or minus 20 so the beta
peptide bundles that we make those are
thorough stable so you can you know 98
degrees in one case and they barely
unfold and so it's kind of interesting
to think about why the proteins that are
found in our cells aren't composed of
the monomers that we used in those
polymers because they just differ by one
carbon and in fact if you look in
meteors right which provides you some
glimpse into the types of molecules that
were available when life began not only
are our alpha amino acids and meteors
but these beta amino acids are found
also and so kind of a simple probably
too simple explanation is that proteins
composed of beta amino acids in fact
would be too stable
to party to function effectively as
molecules in you know in a land that
exists in a body that is at 37 degrees
Celsius yeah I could but we have not
done that I'm not sure who would pay for
that over there I think yeah I think it
has to have an array of side chains
right that that allows it to fold into a
structure that has this hydrophobic core
okay and I don't know if that's possible
with a synthetic protein that has four
different monomers or eight twelve or
twenty and so that's certainly one of
the fundamental questions that we're
trying to ask is that once you change
the basic subunit do the rules about
what what is needed to constitute a
unique structure do they change I think
you first
that's a great question
so I would say I don't okay
I don't but people have been working on
this and there's a fantastically
interesting scientist called David Baker
who works at the University of
Washington who has developed a program
called rosetta which is pretty
successful at starting with a primary
sequence and predicting what structure
it will fold into and even better than
that he can start with the structure
that he wants and identify the sequence
that will fold into that structure and
in fact he just had a paper in nature at
last week where he designed so remember
I showed you the picture of green
fluorescent protein which I thought was
which I said was so amazing because not
only did it fold into the structure but
it has these side chains that react in
the interior and then it flores's well
he was able to design synthetic versions
of green fluorescent protein simply
using Rosetta so and what's even more
amazing about David Baker is that not
only does he do this himself but he
actually just like Richard Oz there's a
program that that you know so called
Rosetta Commons where you know you can
actually go in and interact with him and
try to fold proteins yourself on the
internet so so yes so the answer is I
can't do it
but David Baker can yep
what is why do you advantage is that
well it's not just that it's cooperative
versus non cooperative it's that there's
a unique structure right and so so the
fact that it folds into this cooperative
form you know the form in a sense is
only the first part what's more
important is that form right provides
that protein with the ability to catch
up to promote reactions and support life
and so if you have a form that is many
different structures then it's unlikely
that any one of those structures will be
able to carry out any interesting
chemistry and so the fact that it's
folded into a unique structure provides
it with function okay and its function
that is somewhat tank temperature
resistance and so even if our body
temperature changes by a little bit yeah
it doesn't change the structure I mean
it eventually you can so you know eggs
or proteins and so you can scramble eggs
which is your denaturing them right but
you can you know whether or not the egg
is at four degrees in your refrigerator
or out on the counter it's still liquid
it's still an egg right it's not until
you heat it on a frying pan to a hundred
degrees does it actually unfold and form
a structure that is irreversibly you
know not useful delicious but not useful
yes the one more the woman in pink
yes you can
and in fact there are scientists who
work on that they try to develop
sequences of proteins that have polymer
like properties and so I think one of
the one of the people in that area is a
man named David Terrell who's on the
faculty at Caltech he's now the Provost
at Caltech and that's one of the things
that he's been doing in his lab for for
many decades now how is that going to
work that's actually that's a great
question and so I can I can answer that
with a real-life example and so so I
showed you the protein called silk still
so it turns out that there is a company
cold there actually too one is called
spy Burr and the other is called bolt
threads and I know the technology of
both threads much better so both threads
is a company that has these huge vats
but they're not Pat's of chemicals
they're vats of yeast and the yeast have
ribosomes that make the silk that's made
by spiders and in fact both threads has
figured out how to take the product of
these you know yeast which makes spider
silk and make ties and fabrics and you
can buy a spider silk tie from both
threads and so I think the key if we
want to make fabrics is we're eventually
gonna have to move into an organism like
yeast which can be grown on large scale
just like beer okay but rather than
having the yeast make beer right the
yeast are making materials right using
their own ribosomes and so I don't think
you know I don't see that
of chemicals I think I see bats of yeast
so that's how you scale yes okay so um
so the amino acid that those are truth
is is amino and there's acid okay and so
all amino acid all monomers of proteins
have an amino group and an acid group
and that's why they're called amino
acids so if we go back to the first
slide I can do this
actually maybe not the first slide okay
so for example hold on let me find the
right no no I there's actually a better
picture but you can answer this better
okay so this is an amino acid this is an
amino group and that's an acid group
okay so they're called amino acids
because each monomer has an amino group
and a carboxylic acid
[Applause]
[Music]